hallo wir sind heute bei der bäckerei
und konditorei siebert in berlin
hier arbeitet sony eine easy german
zuschauern aus japan
sie hat uns eingeladen einmal die
bäckerei anzusehen wie gehen rein
[Musik]
hier würden wir mit tommy was hast du
gerade gebacken
ich habe kinder gepackt
jetzt sind sie in der backstube und bei
uns ist der bäckermeister herrn biwaks
witzige backen nur alles was dem
berliner bittere macht also fangen mit
brot angebot sorgen denn hier noch in
kreuzlingen danach brötchen euro
schritten ist es auch ganz viele andere
geworden
zb später brötchen in der wiener
spirituose und gibt es in japan auch
solche bäckereien zu jahr habe für wir
haben keine brot ist nicht so beliebt im
jahr fahren
doch aber junger leute maria maria junge
leute essen brot in java und du lernst
hier wie man brötchen backt und dann
kannst du in japan eine deutsche
bäckerei eröffnen
na ja wie lange gibt es ihre bäckerei
940 wir sind die erste bäckerei in
berlin zum agieren sie wohnen hier die
häuser neu gebaut
das war damals der stadtrand kann man
sich heute gar nicht mehr vorstellen
sind da mittendrin am berliner stadtrand
war mein uropa derzeit wächst gemacht
hatte und seitdem gibt es die bäckerei
also über podcasts ersten weltkrieg
weimarer republik bei den nazis unter
beschuss 40 45 uhr weiter gebacken die
ddr zeit mein vater und seit 1990 noch
nicht wir sind jetzt im verkauf frauen
der hexerei welchen sorten brot haben
wir hier ja wir haben ganz verschiedene
sorten
das hauptziel von mischfonds
das rotieren berlin kann man jetzt
getrost wir für unsere große diese
sorgen
hier werden wir haben uns gebacken
derzeit wird hier geknetet und dann in
brötchen im kleine brötchen und erteilte
tomomi rollt jetzt die brötchen die
brötchen kommen aus schriften brands und
werden dann im ofen gebacken zweit
beliebteste sorte vollkornbrot 100 also
in berlin ist noch offen dient früher da
war so viel als reines roggenbrot aber
es war vollkommen de france mal sehen
wie das von innen aussieht also eher
dunkler in den drang mehr wenn ich
gefragt also so ist das normale rolle
mehr
so sieht's aus die dunkler sind in
manchen industrie sachen die sind die
man gefärbt naja also rang ist es so
dass es normal raum und gefärbt alle
etwas dunkler es ist denn mit schöner
regelmäßigkeit oder und rosinenbrot
weizen bis in dieser teig und innen und
außen positiv bis sie und was haben wir
nach easyjet oder kaviar bord auch in
berlin studieren daher wird jetzt das
ganz edle da wurde sein so hoch keine
schnittchen
die waren ja denn mit mitunter den
kaviar oder also wahrscheinlich daher
fliegt man den kwf zum beispiel sagen
wir jetzt ja schon die bäckerei jetzt
111 jahren ist und früher also war der
tourismus und sonst nicht so verbreitet
wenn ich also hier jeden tag drei die
franzosen hier trendy sondern die waren
selten ich war mal aus von napoleon mal
hier und danach den paarungen genossen
oder so
davor und nur die haben das gegessen die
anderen nur wenn sie schmeißen konnte
nicht aber das war ja relativ teures
mehr getrunken immer einfacher
preiswerter aber sie wachsen jetzt in
der umgebung und in beizen haben sie ja
außenlinie vorher jungs und auch diese
zwei meere ist generell markt da wird ja
mehr sozusagen in der mühle wichtig
müssen mehr vollkorn wurde ganze corning
normalerweise das vollkommenste mir früh
gewesen und so und das war dass sich die
die reichen leisten konnten die
vornehmen obwohl die hälfte sozusagen
der müller weggeschmissen hat und das
außen zu mir dass ich gerne in die
karten
[Musik]
da werden die neuen himmel stangen
angeliefert ist die wachstum jetzt
besonders voll um 10 uhr noch eines
unterschiedliche zeiten immer mal
nochmal frühes ansturm und dann gesagt
aber heute mittwoch und donnerstag ist
ein ruhiger tag verstehen die leute bis
1000 vom sommer bis zur ecke da stehen
wir in fünf verkäuferinnen hier draußen
stehen
70 auf bedeutet so eine lange tradition
hat dann ist das großartig
es ist also hier haben wir verschiedene
kuchensorten das ist eine strecke die
zucker schmecken eine rakete schmecken
amerikaner für das ist ein amerikaner
wartung der heißt so weil dort die
lockerung mit amon junges harmon plätze
in der sprungliste harmonium des
artikels harmonien place ingo lang haben
mit amerikanern zugang ist und was ist
hier am beliebten kein schneefall nieder
jeder hat jeden tag aus an das was er
gerne ist aber sehr viel machen wir fand
ich hätte gerne eine schritte ein kürbis
kern brötchen und so ein halbes roggen
vollkornbrot jannis hast du noch einen
wunsch vielleicht ein kuchen ein
pfannkuchen unternehmen noch ein phantom
dazu wird in berlin heißt das doch mit
talina
mit kers konzerte oder mit glauben
musste
bekomme ich drei euro fünfzig alles drin
wäre schön
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt vier frische brötchen und
ein halbes brot gekauft
das essen gleich zum frühstück das war
unser video aus der bäckerei in berlin
kommt meist vorbei und probiert das
leckere brot in der schönfließer straße
im norden berlins
[Musik]
[Applaus]